-  Okay, here we go.
Switch over to the night camera.
- We're using these
incredible cameras,
gives us the ability to see
all this action at night.
We're seeing an almost
daylight image.
(elephant trumpeting)
- It's amazing to film stuff
that's never been seen.
Scientists don't even know
what happens.
- These two male cheetahs
start hunting at nighttime,
which is
unseen behavior.
One of them's
starting to run in.
The amount of nights
we've been out here...
I can't believe we actually
got that shot finally.
It's brilliant.
(growling)
- We wanted to film the softer side.
- Oh, wow.
- Not many people know that
they live in
these really lovely
family groups.
We're hoping that we can
show a world that no one's seen before.
- We're only beginning
to understand
the strange things
that take place at night.
- It's all very well doing
this sort of thing in daylight.
We're trying to
take it on at night.
That adds layers
and layers of problems.
You obviously look down,
you can't see what's happening.
- Uh, yeah, that looks amazing.
I can just...
- Yeah, it's great. Wow.
- This is definitely one of
the hardest shoots I've been on.
It's about minus 30
out here.
- Having to constantly look out
for predators like bears,
it's a big worry.
Wow. You can actually
see teeth marks
and claw marks where
the bear's been.
- Key here to filming is when they move,
you gotta stick with them,
but in a way where you're not interfering,
especially if they're hunting.
- I'm really, really happy
to have seen that.
Oh, that's so cool.
- Turns us humans
into nocturnal animals.
- Being able to sit out here
with them in the dark
is pretty incredible to see
a new life of an animal.
- We can reveal how magic
the night world really is.
(trumpeting)
- That's really amazing to see.
(lion growling)